I believe the self-driving car has very
strong environmental implications safety
social it'll really phenomenal transform
how many of us live
transition is a major problem for pretty
much every city in the world we're just
not operating cars very fresh me when
you think about cars they have
transformed the cities everything else
they cause traffic jams there's a lot of
congestion a peak capacity highway
highway that's really functioning has
only 6% cars on it and 94% that's the
space between the cars that we need
because we humans we are not that great
a driver imagine a future but your
highways actually work you go on a
highway with your car and left of you is
group of very close distance cars coming
by and you push a button it opens up and
you merge in and then you push the
second button and all of a sudden the
car drives itself all the cars line up
very closely to you you're now in a
train the Train uses the aerodynamics of
a train but it frees your time now
imagine we fill the highway with cars
and pack 50% of the service which means
all of a sudden we have almost no
contestants anymore we would be able to
do away with almost all traffic jams I
start to realize we can actually build
cars that are safe in cars that can
drive themselves cars are as safe as
their drivers are we text while driving
we do all kinds of things that distract
us from the driving tasks almost all
excellent states are caused by lack of
attention on driver errands now with
self-driving technology I think it's
kind of the holy grail for that specific
problem which is we will be able to give
people the mobility that they want
without exposing themselves and others
to the dangers that come with the fact
that they're not quite able to operate
motor vehicles the biggest challenge we
face is to make it really safe we
recently had a situation where a plastic
bag blew across the highway and the car
thought of all the kid flying across the
highway and it sounds funny and it was
certainly something we could fix very
quickly but these type of situations
humans are just really brilliant and
cars have a hard time to be honest so I
believe there's an entire universe of
amazing ideas to be developed and I wish
I lived 200 years later to see them come
to fruition but now is the time to stop
working on them
you